joining us now from Tuscaloosa Alabama
on where this election goes from here is
John Merrill he's the current Secretary
of State from Alabama mr. Merrill we've
heard a lot in the last 24 hours
about state process the state process
when something like this happens it is
true is it not that even if he steps
aside which he says he will not do his
name Roy Moore's name remains on this
ballot that's right Laura
even if judge Moore decides that he
wants to disqualify himself and not
continue his campaign at that point it
will not matter his name will still be
on the ballot even if the Republican
Party decided that they would not
formally continue with their support of
judge Moore as their nominee as it was
confirmed to our office on October the
11th judge Moore's name will remain on
the ballot for the 2012 for for the
December 12th 2017 special general
election and I understand that the
governor today has entertained the idea
of moving the election but it was said
that it would that would only take place
if the White House gave its imprimatur
to that move is that correct is that
report correct well a number of those
issues remain to be explored because our
code is very clear about certain issues
that need to be addressed when it comes
to those actual actions that will occur
that is one that is still up in the air
but one that is certainly being explored
well if in fact he does not step aside
and there is a massive like Lisa
Murkowski style write-in campaign for
let's say I don't know Jeff Sessions or
mold Brooks Jeff Sessions Attorney
General vote maybe it goes back to be
senator who and I'm just speculating or
someone like a mo Brooks you'd have to
have to be a name that everybody can
remember because you have to spell the
name correctly you can't have any
mistake in the name or the ballots or is
invalid so certainly if that write-in
campaign happens it would have to be
overwhelming in order to swap the
Democrat mr. Jones
correct and that would likely not have
no doubt about it no doubt about it
because only two candidates appear on
the ballot today and those candidates
are judge Roy Moore and Doug Jones who's
a former federal prosecutor and if a
write-in effort takes place then that
write-in campaign and that educational
process the Saudi associated with that
campaign is going to take a great deal
of time and energy and effort in order
to educate our people on what they need
to do about casting their ballot for
someone that's not currently on the
ballot and that's why you would need
more time in order to get that word out
correct
that's not why why the election could be
moved if indeed that ends up being the
decision of the state party which we
haven't heard a lot from the state party
saying just me well I think there are a
number of conversations that are ongoing
but of course the state party is in a
very difficult position as well as they
try to determine what their intentions
are and where they need to go and I know
that those conversations will continue
to take place over the next few days
maybe even a week or so depending on
what other information is introduced
next week as this saga continues do you
do you know mr. Moore judge Moore I do
know judge Moore yes ma'am no do you
think about these allegations
well I'm very surprised that this
information has just been introduced I
think that's the most interesting part
of it to me I think it's odd that these
revelations have just been introduced
considering the fact judge Moore has
stood for election eight times in our
state for different offices he's been a
public figure for more than 30 years in
the state of Alabama and it's very
difficult for a lot of people in our
state to believe that because of his
history and because of the controversy
that has surrounded Judge Moore in his
public service that this type of
information is only now being introduced
by someone of course these charges are
very very serious and they need to be
given the full measure of vetting that
would be necessary to determine their
validity and I think that most of our
people are still convinced that in order
for someone to be removed from the
ballot or to even remove themselves or
to have the state party completely
removed from the ballot that's the thing
and that's why the timing of this
interesting
he cannot be removed from the bid to
disqualify that exactly to disqualify
themselves from consideration for people
not to vote for them because those names
cannot be removed we're within a
scenario not to play like hypothetical
hero one more scenario let's say he
don't separate himself or the Republican
part of the state separates itself from
judge more and he also vows out he still
wins let's say he still has the most
votes that election is then null and
void correct and the election results
could go to the Democrat correct no
anybody more disqualifies that is
correct if judge Moore disqualifies
himself or if the state party rescinds
their nomination and their endorsement
of him and if those activities occur
formally that means we receive
information in the office of the
Secretary of State that would indicate
that that is indeed the case then at
that point our election would be null
and void and we would have to hold a new
election and Senator strange would
continue to serve in that seat as the
temporary appointment until another
senator was duly elected Wow and sworn
in according to the Constitution that
that would be quite something oh we
really appreciate this is a complicated
process we appreciate it thanks so much
thank you